المختار العبلاوي من الدار البيضاء
المختار الاحتفالات ايضا في المغرب الهدف
واحد طبعا لكن الاحتفالات اللي طعم مغاير
كما جرت العاده تفضل المختار
[موسيقى]
نعم للفعل هنا الاحتفالات كبيره جدا
[تصفيق]
الى الشوارع للاحت
في هذا الانجاز غير المسبوق الكره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاسلاميه
قال كبار السن جميعا الفئات العمريه خرجوا
للاحتفال
وقت التشريع المنتخب المغربي على هذا
الاداء الذي قدمه الان من شعارات التي
تردد يسير سير الى الامام بمعنى ايها
المنتخب المغربي
تقدم الى الامام من اجل المواصله ولما لا
الفوز بالكاس ناخذ الان بعض ردود الفعل
بعد هذا الانتصار
اذا ما هو رايك ياتيك مغربي اليوم
المغربي وعلى جميع العرب شكرا بزاف شكرا
[تصفيق]
الملك محمد السادس
ايضا ايضا
قال شاركوا راي طفله مغربيه ما هو رايك
[موسيقى]
الاجواء من مدينه الدار البيضاء المغربيه
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]